знову українці важко виступати після
генерала за бродського, бо ви
якимось чином читає думки
але тим не менш нагадаю ще раз сьогодні
у червні 2020 року у центрі києва столиці
України
громадяни України змушені захищати
державна мова прихована
українську мову копіювали напувалки
[оплески]
я говорив кажу і говоритиму ні
ніяких чуток українського народу є
слуги кремля
інакше бути не може чотирнадцятому році
на нашу землю прийшли російські
окупанти
я все своє життя прожив мелітополь і
запорізького госпіталях ожити міста
російською мовою
я навчався у школі російською мовою та
вивчав українську мову звичайно я її
знаю і коли не брати я не розумію що у
вас тут написано я розумію тільки точок
і бреше та бреше та маніпулює все
громадяни України школі по інституту
особі тому
вивчали українську означає він розуміє про
чим йдеться і коли ворог пройшло на
нашу землю
вони свято вірили в те, що ось там на
схід та на південному сході україни живуть
російськомовна гра і не ліжко
червону доріжку сраном російському світу та
отруйна російська весна так і не
прочитали і вони прийшли і щось у них не
вийшло
прорахувалися знову тому що сімдесят
та вісімдесят відсотків особового складу
батальйону до бригад які
дислокувалися там на півдні та південному сході
україни були російськомовними і взяли в
руки зброю і пішли військкомат і тому
що сказали в труні я бачив таких
братів які приходять мій будинок зовні
ворогові я такий братський народ який
приходить буде вам зі зброєю який
хоче убити мене мою сім'ю моїх рідних і
близьких
навіть ті хто сидіння і стане весь
російський світ не вірите запитайте у тих хто
загинув під крітами у маріуполі 24 січня
2015 року, а чому ви так зробили
ми все-таки з російськомовною наш уже
прочитали
ми повинні були відвідати потерти червону
доріжку тому що ми громадяни України
від якої показано на україні захист
своєї землі на свої екрани всієї України
розумієте все і цілком це емово
це і віра це і армія це і герб power
gem це навіть ця лавка де у дитячий
сидів бовтав ногами і їв немиту спірс з
дерева це вся україна та україну ми
захищатимемо цілком чого б нам це
не варто і в полоні зараз захищають
цілком для того, щоб слуги кремля
відповіли собі на запитання якщо в Україні
міг на харчування утискають і тут україна
російськомовний і клуні ущемляють потрібно
поїхати на схід спуститися першою
бліндаж, що попався, де-небудь в районі
широке бо авдіївці і пішов ока і
посидіти там тиждень просто посидіти в
куточку попити каву
послухати хлопців і одразу дійде миттєво
що немає повного катували тому що там
армія тому що вам координати братніх
окупантів передаються до російської та
український результат рядку який тут
нагадувати не можна 300 ватів це все
Зрозуміло, де знаходиться що з ними потрібно
робити і хлопці зніміть
в Україні про це як про вдачу
україні державному державному
травня put it with key українсько-українською
9 наші будинки в лазні на риболовлі розібрати
охоче китайською якщо ви розумієте але
освіта українська на основі соки 1 квача
не українську
на сто п'ятсот і радіо блискавка пісні
українську на слові 100 та 110 себе стали
за собою масову дошку котлети журнали
і такі ніші на такі залишки в
українську по ви nabucco
якщо комусь проситься у цій країні
друга державна мова російська
які проблеми така країна є
пасмо називається росія там
державних зафарбувати ніж втіхи
продають на поїзди ходять
будь ласка їдь насолоджуйтесь великим
російським духом
офіс в україні державного повторюю
витоку українців і якщо вони цього не
розуміють
якщо вони ж себе відкусити трохи вони
не вони атакують мову прямо вони
спробували трохи відкусити трошки
пересунути кордон по Україні такий
боргу гілки у чотирнадцятому році
трохи пересунути відкусити один
шматочок другий шматочок третій шматочок 5
відсадження зрештою не залишиться
ніякої України буде федеральний
придніпровський та задніпровський
округ Росії прийняти не буде його
ніколи я вам гарантую бойові
побратими качан дзвонять круто
хлопці знов у 1 0 той кіт що там
відбувається зараз я передам все знову ту
мене виженуть зі сцени і як-не-як
армійська мова якою відразу сотку на
підганяти вони, а потім захист привід варі
тому що ті хлопці, які стоять
ставлю на сході
що тих від мирне небо в тому числі
для цих засранців вони знають ціну світу
не знати, що таке україна для них
україна виділити всіх вся україна цілком
як багато
так віра так прапор їм і такі ніші і я
звертаюся відвалу народу
скажімо так останнє китайське
попередження
дайте спокій це іржа ну богу
займаєтесь політикою займатися
економікою
сало якщо тато і тримав розум інакше якщо
українці розлютуються
вам небо здадуться начинку на україні
[оплески]